zach allen
who looks to run the anchor leg in what
we hope will be a four-game relay sweep
here but he gets to be the follow-up
back for tyler gilbert's no-no last
night well that would be nice if he
could follow that up with another one of
his own today but really we just want to
see zach pitch well enough to give the
d-backs a chance to win they've lost 10
of his last 11 starts fernando tatis jr
great to be able to say his name again
he'll be leading things off for the
padres injured himself july 30th at the
bottom of the first inning sliding into
third base in that game against the
rockies out for 13 games and now in
there and leading off for the first time
since may 9. i look at fernando tati's
junior and it's like a kid who's been
penned up in the uh the house all day
and then all of a sudden he gets to go
out and play he is so happy he cannot
wait
it's sharply and off the glove at third
base of ellis down the left field line
as fernando heads for second base he'll
get there standing a double in his
return first a b fort fernando he's got
extra bases we're on the corners with a
one out for corningward
got him two outs it's a big out number
two ahead of tommy fan
high fly ball right field for pavon
smith drifting back to the warning track
and gallon strands too between innings
here and the introduction of the author
of last night's no-hitter tyler gilbert
wait what a moment that just keeps on
keeping on for tyler gilbert it was so
amazing greg stamen on the mound for
another start his third of the year and
he's allowed four runs six hits across
two innings that was against miami that
was the second start of the season he's
a ground ball pitcher when he's out with
that two seamer in that slider almost 60
percent ground ball rate for craig
stamen fernando tatis jr of course is
out in right field so this is his first
inning ever
as an outfielder in professional
baseball david peralta here with a man
in scoring position two on and two outs
here he is
peralta hits the fly ball to right field
and over his tatis to make the catch his
first try in the majors top of the order
against zach gallon that means fernando
tatis jr coming up again fernando on the
fourth pitch that he saw leading off the
game doubled
high fly ball to deep left field for
fernando it's back towards the wall and
it is gone
fernando's done it again in his first
game back off the i alley homers and
fernando tatis jr puts the padres on top
one to nothing
welcome back el nino third time this
year he homers in his first hit bat off
the injured list boy you talk about an
adrenaline shot just having him in the
lineup pumping up the team pumping up
the fans after the lack of offense
already a double and a home run an
absolute no dollar right off the bat he
is something here comes martinez strike
out swinging first time up on still
holding that's by hosmer down the line
it's all the way in the corner
rojas coming in martay heading for third
here's the throw when it's cut off to
tell martin the rbi triple and we're
tied at one there's cabrera now trying
to bring him in one is lined off of
kneer's bare hand then caught at
shortstop by cronenworth unbelievable
a line drive up the middle it caught
kneer on the bare hand and before it hit
the ground jake cronin worth snagged it
now is kneer okay he will stay in for
now and hopefully he doesn't swell up on
it bam slide out to right to win the
first
and drills one to center can't tell
has got it
outstanding running sliding play out
there picking that ball right off the
turf fernando tati's junior leading off
already two for two with a double and a
homer and the 2-0 change up to fernando
is hung and hitting the air out to deep
left field again peralta going back he's
at the wall it's gonna go
another one for fernando
he's three for three with a couple of
homers and a double in his return and
the padres are back in front two to one
and we are out of word it's like he's
playing on a playground at school and
he's the best player out there
absolutely incredible mvp is right jay
chronis stands in with one out and one
on
this pitch is hitting the air out to
deep right field by cronin north smith
is going back he will look up and this
one's going to go that's into the chrome
zone in arizona a two-run home run for
cronenworth and the padres take a 4-1
lead number 17 for jake crowdenwood
leadoff
[Applause]
diamondbacks answer right back that's
number 11 for josh
what a series he's had he's had nine
hits fernando tatis jr he's in right
field as a lot of the people around the
padres had anticipated he would be when
he came back as ahmed swings here pops
it up into shallow right fernando tatis
jr comes in makes a two-handed catch and
made that look awfully routine runner on
third two outs in the bottom of the
seventh inning padres lead the
diamondbacks four to two drupal cabrera
coming up now for arizona singled in the
first lined out in the third and then
struck out in the fifth
fly ball shallow right out as frazier
tatis and fernando calls him off that
makes the catch
third catch he's made in right field in
his first game ever in right field right
hand desean popping ball from reno today
they'll face the pinch hitter will myers
that is ball four so eventually he walks
and it'll load the bases
and the bases will be loaded for
fernando tatis jr 4 12 when the base is
loaded three grand slams on his resume
line into center field a base hit that
will score for carratini grisham behind
him throw goes to third it's a two-run
single
for fernando tatis junior and the padres
take a 6-2 lead fourth hit of the day
for fernando he's driven in four runs
welcome back nando jake cronenworth at
the plate his base is full in two outs
that's ball four that'll drive in a run
7-2 padres as myers makes his way in
from third
bam the ninth man to bat in the first
pitch goes to the backstop that'll get
another run home fernando scampers
across the plate a wild pitch makes it
eight to two batista's day is done he's
done enough
a double a single two homers he's
knocked in four runs and his return from
the injured list marshall who had a big
series pinch hitting here with two outs
in the inning
ground ball right side this should do it
cronenworth to first ball game is over
as the padres
salvage a final game of the series they
needed that in the big way as they get
the return of fernando tatis jr and he
comes up huge today in his return four
hits four rbis two home runs all adds up
to a padres win as they win at eight to
two